we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p take a listen to this caller
it hey David I was listening to your
your segment on the bonus show about
hamburgers and it actually is acceptable
to eat a burger upside down right the
reason being is you've got all these
toppings on the top you want the
toppings to be close to your tongue yeah
so that you can taste all of the the
flavors together with though that's what
the burger and the topic you know I
don't think that's weird I don't think
that's a legal so there you have it ya
know and it was never an issue of
criminality per se but it was an issue
of what would you call that an issue of
taste I think it was an issue of ethics
exactly so yeah and if people haven't
been following this I did disclose and I
have in the past that I tend to when I
eat a burger if you imagine the fillings
between two pieces of bread as I'm
demonstrating if you imagine that the
sesame seed bun is on top with the
sesame seeds up what I do is I pick up
the burger and flip it as I bring it up
to my mouth right and the sesame seeds
are now on the bottom and that's how I
bite it and it is true that typically
you've got all sorts of seasonings and
condiments on the top of the burger and
this caller couldn't be more right in
saying that you are really putting the
flavor right on the taste buds when you
flip it in that way and really it feels
very awkward to me to sort of like bring
the burger up will while keeping the
sesame seed bun on top a vegan gluten
free sesame seed bun naturally so I do
believe that I am eating the burger in
the right way and I think let's put this
issue to rest you know people are trying
to turn it into a scandal but I just
think that there's nothing here let's
move on and on the bonus show today
speaking of moving on it turns out that
Rand Paul got into a physical
altercation with his neighbor very weird
very very weird story has a number of
broken ribs and we're going to talk
about that on the bonus show also you
often hear that idea that hey I'm
already pregnant so I don't need birth
control what's gonna happen I'm gonna
get pregnant again it actually happened
to a woman she was pregnant and she
became pregnant again how did it happen
we will talk about it on the bonus show
and lastly yet another
in California this time of how the law
is preventing former inmates former
convicted felons from getting jobs
particularly in this case jobs that they
sort of had already proven themselves
qualified for it's a story about
firefighting Southern California and
those horrible wildfires that have been
raging if you're wondering why my hair
looks like I might have stuck my finger
in an electrical socket it is because we
did indeed hit 2,000 patrons over the
weekend at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show I promise to do my hair or
not do my hair I guess the answer or
explanation would really be when we
reach 2,000 patrons and I've done it I
have held up my end of the bargain and
now I am inviting you to help us with
our next goal which is 2500 patrons when
we reach 2500 patrons my Boston College
epistemology critical thinking and media
literacy class will be recorded produced
and edited and ultimately uploaded to
YouTube ok so that's a lot of work and
in order to fund that project we are
fundraising on patreon patreon comm
slash David Pakman show 2500 is the
target you also get access to the bonus
show at the $5 a month level on patreon
and of course Old Faithful membership is
still there at david pakman.com slash
membership regular rates six bucks a
month 60 for the year you can get a 40%
discount with the coupon code
I voted 17 and of course the Amazon link
is gone it was destroyed last Monday I
thought that I had recreated it in a
sort of less successful way but we have
now been notified that the Amazon link
is over and done with completely and
it's that it's very very low energy but
we are doing everything we can to take
care of that problem and fix it with
patreon and membership all right I've
gone on far too long we will talk to you
on the bonus show today